more cheers from those who don't want
independence results from voting
districts across Scotland revealed a
clear win for the No campaign the yes
campaign suffered disappointments
including in districts that were
heartlands of the ruling Scottish
National Party which spearheaded the
campaign its leader Alex Salmond
admitted defeat and it's important to
say that our referendum was an agreed
and consented process and Scotland has
by majority decided not at this stage to
become an independent country I accept
that verdict of the people and I call on
all of Scotland to follow suit after
months of campaigning and debate the 4.3
million eligible voters were deeply
divided I voted yes because I think
Scotland will be more democratic we
won't have to live under Conservative
government to Gabe hell of Scotland and
I want it to mean the same an adultress
Alex Island simple as many in the yes
campaign spent all night on the streets
hoping that the Rising Sun would bring
with it a new dawn for Scotland's you're
very excited to be hopeful
hope you get the right result tomorrow
the atmosphere is amazing
feels great to get part of the whole
movement the no vote won the day but
that may not simply mean a return to the
status quo in the lead-up to the vote
Westminster politicians promised
Scotland more powers if it voted to stay
in the UK